thanks to curiositystream and nebula for
sponsoring this video
so um
i got married and it turns out that we
went on honeymoon on the train through
france and spain at the worst possible
time for a climate-based youtuber
because
i missed all the news thing is
perhaps you did too yes biden's climate
bill got passed and that's received tons
of attention already in particular hank
green's done an excellent breakdown here
on youtube but two huge other stories
also happened in august and received
only perfunctory coverage in western
media i'm talking about the floods in
pakistan which have got a bit more
attention and the heatwave and drought
in china which you may not be aware of
but should be to bring you up to speed
starting in late august pakistan
experienced its worst flooding this
century like at one point a third of the
country was under water and this has
been a disaster this has displaced
something like 33 million people and
killed as of the time of recording
1300 people in china however the problem
is not too much water but not enough
specifically the yangtze which is the
third largest river in the world is
incredibly low right now now you may
have heard that the rhine was so low
this summer that scuttled nazi ships
became visible well in chongxing the
yangtze became so low that buddhist
statues were revealed that were 600
years old the river flow is 50 percent
lower than the average of the past five
years this is a really historic drought
in china right now it's a big deal for
movement on the river which is crucial
to both the chinese and the global
economy to the supply of drinking water
but also to the ability to generate
hydro power sichuan where the yangtze
flows gets 80 percent of its electricity
from hydro and this summer demand is up
by 25
and the available water has gone down by
50 that's not good naturally the
question to ask here is why why are
these things happening and the answer is
as you've probably already pieced
together likely climate change but
expressed in two very different ways the
floods in pakistan were preceded by an
extreme heat wave earlier this summer as
was reported in nature in april and may
temperatures reached above 40 degrees
celsius for prolonged periods in many
places on one sweltering day in may the
city of jacobabad topped 51 degrees
celsius for those working in fahrenheit
that's a lot
the extreme heat resulted in extreme
melting of the glaciers that feed into
the indus river which of course
increased the water level this combined
with an unusual low pressure system in
the persian gulf and crucially an early
onset at the monsoon bringing torrential
rain resulted in a perfect storm and far
more water than the rivers and lakes
could handle at once in china there was
also an extreme heat wave earlier this
summer but this one was extraordinary
noticing a pattern southern china
recorded its longest period of
continuous high temperatures since
records began now admittedly that's only
since the 1960s because of china in the
20th century but the numbers stand on
their own an all-time temperature record
for china excluding the desert-dominated
xinjiang region was set of 45 degrees
celsius in bay bay for two consecutive
days and the city was over 40 degrees
celsius for a record 11 days meanwhile a
record nighttime temperature of
34.9 degrees celsius was set in nearby
chonsing and i just i can't imagine
trying to sleep in that in fact that's
probably where the extra energy demand
came from whether historian maximiliano
herrera was quoted in new scientists
saying that this might be the most
severe heat wave recorded
anywhere this combines the most extreme
intensity with the most extreme length
with an incredibly huge area all at the
same time in his opinion there is
nothing in world climatic history which
is even minimally comparable to what is
happening in china unlike in pakistan
however the extreme heat didn't result
in extreme rain in fact the opposite
happened and rainfall dried up as did
the nation's rivers blaming both of
these events which are kind of polar
opposites to each other on climate
change then
sounds a little nonsensical but it is
actually what we would expect to happen
in a warming world the thing to remember
about the climate crisis is that it's
not that the earth's temperature is
increasing the amount of energy in the
earth system is increasing now that
largely means that temperatures will
increase but they won't increase
uniformly the same everywhere because by
adding more energy to the system you're
changing how that system works and based
on our current understanding we think
that that means more likely a more
intense maxima of temperatures in other
words heat waves further for each degree
celsius the air warms it can hold about
seven percent more moisture as the earth
has warmed by about a degree celsius
since pre-industrial times we have
measured an increase in the amount of
water held in the earth's atmosphere
that has two important implications
firstly because water is a greenhouse
gas the increase in humidity amplifies
any warming caused by carbon dioxide so
it's a positive feedback and secondly
more water in the atmosphere means that
more precipitation
rainfall is possible but because the
amount of energy in the system has
increased that doesn't mean that
precipitation will just increase
everywhere changes in precipitation
patterns mean that while many areas will
get wetter some will get drier and we
can expect an increase in extremes on
both ends both wet and dry as the planet
warms so while these events are shocking
they're not unexpected but that's only
if you hear about them in the first
place in covering the news obviously
there's a bias towards stories and
topics that affect the viewer or the
reader so here in the uk we mostly hear
about news in the uk
unfortunately and only hear about events
in pakistan and china if it's pretty
important stuff and i recognize that if
we reported on all the bad stuff
happening in the world we'd probably all
find it hard to get out of bed in the
morning because it would be overwhelming
but at the same time i'm a little aghast
at how little coverage the chinese
heatwave and to a lesser extent the
pakistani floods have received
these are huge climate events and they
do affect you they affect you through
how interconnected the world economy is
and specifically because of how much
manufacturing the west has outsourced to
china and that is going to be affected
by this and it affects you because
you're living in the same atmosphere as
china and pakistan and in a changing
climate that could see similar events
happening to you next but perhaps most
importantly they affect you because
you're a human being too the reason i
wanted to make this video is because on
twitter in response to news of this
heatwave many people reacted with glee
saying that it's good that china is
suffering under the climate crisis that
it has caused that this was some kind of
justice firstly this to me is
an unfathomably callous attitude i mean
if we're talking about chongxing being
nearly 35 degrees celsius at night
that's a city the size of london
you're full of people just like you
trying to live their lives
like the misery the sheer misery that
this heat wave has inflicted on people
let alone the excess deaths which
obviously we're not close to calculating
yet that misery has afflicted 900
million people again
people like you
this is awful and secondly who is
responsible for the climate crisis
not china what matters when it comes to
trapping more energy in the earth's
atmosphere is the total amount of carbon
put into it and when looking at the
cumulative emissions of co2 to date
china is responsible for about 12.7
percent of all the carbon put into the
atmosphere to date
compare that to europe's 22
and the usa's 25
yes china has the largest emissions of
any country right now but each chinese
citizen produces half the co2 of an
american there just so happens to be
over a billion chinese citizens so to
wish harm on one of them for causing
climate change isn't just morally wrong
it's factually wrong
i think one of the reasons why people
may have this attitude is because
quality coverage of the climate crisis
can be hard to come by i'm i'm guessing
for example that a lot of this video was
news to you
so if you like me would like to stay up
to date on this physical side of the
climate crisis then i have some
recommendations i've mentioned them
before but carbon brief is i think the
best website for climate news and you
can sign up for their multiple
newsletters on different aspects of the
crisis i'd also recommend checking out
skeptical science which is a website
that mostly focuses on debunking myths
about climate change but also has a
newsletter that summarizes the latest
research in climate you can also go a
bit closer to the source if you like and
sign up for updates from journals like
science and nature which summarize the
research for you and provide links to
the papers themselves for further
reading and lastly if you're on twitter
there are any number of accounts i could
recommend following but two would be
scott duncan
and catherine heiho ultimately what i'm
getting at here is that what is
happening in china and in pakistan
matters to you it matters economically
it matters morally and it matters
because the scale of heat of drought and
a flood happening on the other side of
the world is happening in a changing
climate a climate that you
share the way that we talk about stories
from this changing climate is important
in response to a global threat we cannot
afford to be tribal we cannot afford to
disregard data
what is happening to people on the other
side of the world is relevant to you
and i think you owe it to yourself
to learn about their stories
of course somewhere else that you can
learn about this changing climate is
from myself from our changing climates
from real engineering from second
thought and from many other creators on
nebula who have kindly sponsored this
video nebula as you've probably heard by
now is the streaming service with over
half a million users that is owned and
operated by a group of educational
youtubers including me on nebula you get
early access to our content bonus videos
and entirely original content such as
extremities by wendoverproductions and
do so without an ad in sight nebula has
no ads instead operating on a
subscription model and that subscription
also gives you access to curiosity
stream the number one source of high
quality documentaries on the web they
have thousands of titles across every
subject you can think of and have plenty
about china specifically including the
colors of china a series examining how a
philosophy of color thousands of years
old is still relevant to a billion
people today you can get access to the
big budget documentaries of curiosity
stream and the indie productions of
nebula at curiositystream.com
simon clark also linked below which
gives you a 26 discount on both that's
just over a dollar a month for the best
bits of youtube without the ads and an
endless supply of thought-provoking
documentaries for all ages with thanks
to curiositystream and nebula for
sponsoring this video
thank you very much for watching this
video half of the sponsorship money from
it is going to be donated to relief
efforts in pakistan i'll also include a
link down there in the description if
you would like to donate to try and help
people overcome this disaster if you'd
like to hear more about what happened
with the wedding and just generally how
i make these videos then you can watch
the behind the scenes vlog available on
my patreon patrons get access to a
behind the scenes vlog every month as
well as getting early access to these
videos and now a couple of votes every
now and again choosing a topic for a
video so if that all sounds good and
you'd like to support this channel
please do check out my patreon also
linked below here's some recommended
viewing next and i hope that you enjoyed
this video and took something away from
it please do pop it a like if you did
and that just leads me to say thank you
again for watching i'll see you in the
next one